i don't know how do you do it how do you
react to this [ __ ] i
just most of the time i'm
able to just move forward
like i try not to get stuck in it and i
think that
that's like when i talk to people who
really get
caught up in it it's like the difference
between me and them
in those moments is that i don't
keep thinking about it like i just
go okay that's just the way it is right
now and i can
step back and not get completely
invested
i'm not like that all the time but with
certain things that feel
very out of my control i am
i am you let them go quickly
yeah i let them go why do i linger on
them like a cranberry song
that i don't know michael why do you i
don't know i think because my mind's
going
a million miles an hour i'm doing all
these things and um
it's not that i expect everything to be
smooth sailing and
and happen and and be fine and be great
and i know there are things along the
way there are bumps along the road
on the road whatever but i i think
i do get a little overwhelmed at things
it you know especially when when that
hits when it's one thing after another
i try to do the breathing i try and then
also i'm drinking a coke i'm
uh you know i'm not exercising as much
and i kind of go down i'm like
what are you doing if you just kind of
realize maybe that hey stop
go back to the routine go back to do you
have a routine
yeah i was gonna say though i think a
part of what i do
too though is i don't overload myself i
don't like having a ton of stuff on my
plate
and so i try and keep it so that i don't
like i don't like it when i have it
like i do get stressed out when i have a
lot so i kind of control my life a
little bit so that i don't have those
moments that you're talking about we're
all piles on top of each other
because then i feel like i'm scrambling
and i can't keep up so like part of how
i manage it is i just don't have
as many things that i'm doing like i
feel like you do a lot of things
okay i think you're caught in your first
lie because you're going back to school
you're on a show you uh you know
i mean you do a lot of things but maybe
you are able to not spread yourself too
thin and go i could handle this i could
handle this and when something you can't
right yeah i guess maybe it's more like
i have a sense of what i can handle and
i
i don't push myself too far beyond what
i think i can handle
that's good do you get annoyed easily i
mean i know you do because you got
annoyed with me sometimes on the set
but sometimes especially if i'm tired
do you know yeah or when you're hungry
yes
i i get like that we get we get angry
but like you're dating someone
do you do you find yourself like why why
did i just get annoyed oh i'm sorry
that was such a small thing you did but
for some reason it pissed me off
absolutely
especially during covid that's
definitely
it's more annoying like why are you
eating the cake
while it's in the fridge why not remove
it from the fridge and then eat the cake
is this necessary to
oh there's a printer going off in my
office that's fine
yeah oh yes the answer is yes
well if i were him i'd say cause i'm a
guy
this is what we do i have an arnold
palmer it's a jug of arnold palmer iced
tea
of course i live alone it's different
but i
open the fridge and i give a little
chuggy chug because no one else is going
to go in there and probably drink my
iced tea unless they ask me and i'll say
hey i just chugged on that you might
want to be
right but are you spilling your iced tea
into the fridge
okay now we're getting somewhere so
you're saying he's a little bit
messy he spills cake in the fridge
it's really irrelevant in the grand
scheme of life
but in the moment at times it can be
annoying
i think what's funnier is the
conversation maybe you have an hour
later where you're like
um sweetheart i don't know if you call
him sweetheart maybe honey bunny
but perhaps you just say the keg
incident
i mean you're you're a pig but i
shouldn't have reacted like that and um
sorry about the cake fight yeah i mean
it doesn't ever get to fight
fight land but definitely it is it is
strange so you don't fight
i think we we don't have like fight
fights
um we'll like disagree or have an
argument about something but we don't
like
i don't like we don't have yelling
fights i can't
imagine you yelling i would love if just
on this podcast one time you just laid
into me
yeah i won't do that that's highly
unlikely you never yell when's the last
time you yelled
at work because it was in a scene oh it
was the writing i liked the uh
so so so you were in a moment and you
had to yell because it's written and
you're acting yelling
yeah i've yelled in previous in previous
relationships
you know it's come to yelling um
but only if someone else yells first
right i mean you had a good upbringing
were your parents yellers
no they were they were quietly punishing
quietly punishing that sounds like a
song when you say
that you do something and in in a very
subtle way
not to say they could shame you but
they'll say something that's just
oh they know how to get under my skin
without doing anything much of anything
yeah but there were lots of rules in my
household you had to follow the rules
what were the rules please you can't go
out
can't date people you can't wear makeup
you can't do anything you can't watch
certain shows if there's kissing in them
well didn't you kiss tom on smallville
oh that's different that's when i'm
older when you're an adult it's fine
there's rules when you're like
growing up in a household but you still
live with your parents for
uh until you were what 19 yeah but my
parents are very interesting they
they have a they're very clear like when
a kid turns 18 they are an adult
and when they're an adult everything
stops
there they don't try and parent they
don't
get too involved they don't demand my
time
or my energy they're like you do your
life
we'll support you in the ways you want
to be supported and we'll back off if he
wants to back off
and i feel no pressure from that wait a
minute so
it's like when's your birthday again
december 30th right december 3rd i
wanted to say earlier december but i'm
glad you said it first because then i
didn't look wrong
so on december 29th they might have been
kind of rude and said yogurt you're
going to do this you're going to do that
and then the second you turn
uh 18 i'll let her leave her alone
pretty much that was their theory and
and i'm really as i
see some of my friends and their
relationships with their parents like
i'm really glad that they did that like
i just don't
feel the weight of them at all